I don't want your marriage doomed and I
don't want your finances doomed if he's
truly concerned about the price of the
wedding get married at the courthouse
and do a party later after you got your
house like it doesn't have to be all
that you you can't get out of the house
there's no I mean when you go through a
divorce the judge tells you what you
have to do when your girlfriend leaves
and you got the whole mortgage and her
name's still on it and you can't find
her to get the deed signed cuz she got
remarried somewhere or got married to
somebody else somewhere and and now
we're trying to get rid of the house
it's a dadgum nightmare don't do that
people get yourself in a mess